hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the TCC Superfinal season 17
it's a game 16 Lee watch a zero again
with the white pieces against stockfish
and it's quite a quite a weird game
again
Lila does anything to win but on the
other hand it's a really gruesome game
really takes takes like forever but you
know for those of you who really want to
check it out you are welcome to stay and
enjoy it
so without further ado let's check it
out Lila would the white pieces opens
with E 4 we have g6 modern defense by
stockfish d-4d 6/9 to see three and a
six and up until this point the the
opening has been pre-arranged and the
bush of the e3 is the first move played
in the game basically by Lila we have
Bishop to g7 I've been getting the dark
square Bishop h4 now in in the style of
alpha 0 we have h5 and now Knight to h3
and this is nothing new all been played
before between humans with Bishop
captures rook characters and the Knight
to d7 and now Queen - e - there is one
game from 2009 gear room R vs Peter
Svidler that ended in a draw
where Meyer went for Queen to d2 but
here like I said Quinta e - and it is a
new move by Leela I saw as a move 8 we
have a completely new game Queen to see
it by stockfish are preparing c5 as
Leela will most likely Castle queenside
livadas Castle queenside and now c5
trying to bust open the center at the
start and attack against Lila's King we
have King to be one a nice prophylactic
move and b5 now further expanding on the
Queen side with Knight to d5 an
excellent outpost for tonight and now
Knight G to f6 challenging the knife
there sorry Knight G to f6 challenging
the knight on d5 and also developing we
have D captures on c5 now Knight
captures sorry
Knight characters on d5 first eek a
person d5 ended Knight captures on c5 so
stock whisking stone in the center of
the board but currently very safe so
Bishop to d4 opening up
attack towards the bishop and here stuff
is just castles saying do you want to
capture perhaps my e7 pawn and indeed if
you go for the East seven point you've
grabbed a pawn but you you expose your
Queen to all sorts of attacks such as
rook to e8 and then you don't really
have all that many squares for your
queen you could go for Queen captures
here but then Queen captures on d4 now
comes with an attack on the rook and
also with a double attack and the bishop
here so black would be of course
completely winning here so after this
castles a b7 pawn is off-limits
we have rooked III now going after the
pawn this way and Queen to f5 saying
again help yourself to the pawn so
what's what's the idea behind grabbing
the poor now well if rook captures on e7
now again just the bishop character
sandy for rook captures in the Queen to
f6 now with an attack on the roof here
and putting pressure on the e7 rook and
after this route goes back just a nice
nice East six challenging the rook and
it's now you have to go back work the b7
for example and then Knight the c5
attacks it again and so on if you go
rook rook the c7 then you can go look
look the I ate and well this rook could
be a bit out of place and it's unclear
whether it's gonna be useful or not but
as they both agreed that the e7 points
off limits I probably would be more of a
liability then then an advantage so not
going for the pawn we've G 3 by Leela
and now Bishop to f6 now strengthening
the pawn but also if Bishop captures it
then you can capture with the e pawn
opening of the e-file for the rook so F
3 and now preparing to further push with
the g4 but now bunch of characters on d4
we're group captors on d4 n now rook to
a7 again adding one of the defenders to
them to the e7 pawn and the Queen to d2
now again you you could grab the pawn
but again Levi decides against it
because after this you just give up the
f3 pawn and it doesn't seem like you
want all the
much the bishop on f1 is hanging and so
on
so after rook to e7 we have Queen back
to d2 and now comes Queen to f6 with a3
strengthening the position on the Queen
side and looked the b7 now preparing
before we've looked at for now attacking
the Queen Queen to h8 and the Queen t1
now again putting pressure on the e7
pawn rook to e8 defending and now g4
finally deciding to bust open the
position we have Queen to h6 putting
pressure on the rook here look the B for
stopping before and Queen back to h8 and
again rook to f4 a retreating with the
rook Quinta h6 and rook to b4 and the
Queen tha and Leela again has the option
of repeating moves and grabbing a draw
but decides against it and pushes g5 g
captures and h5 seems a bit better but
the problem is black is much faster
faster in this race for example if Queen
captures here you're going to go back
Ruby for preparing rook g5 but then rook
eat a b8 rook to g5 you're gonna move
the Queen and after h5 ESU you bust open
but b4h captors and g6 you're just gonna
capture on a3 and even after this check
King captures on f7 it's uh
there's no way to continue the attack
for white and black is threatening
checkmate one and once you give a check
King goes to e8 there's no way to
continue this attack be the 7 point is
nicely protected by the rook
so after this Queen date rate not
captures but rather g5 by Leela and okay
this gives new life and new meaning to
the position and stalkerish now starts
the regroup King h7 and okay we have
King to a to rook to e7 now may be
preparing room b8 and starting to push
on the Queen side and now rogue back to
f4 threatening the f7 pawn so Queen g7
defending and now c3 and now creating a
blockade here on before Queen to f8 and
now comes a rook to d4 we have E 5 now
and D captures an e6 on Poisson with F
captures on e6 and Queen to d2 now
putting pressure on
pawn here we have d5 not allowing the
capture and now a Bishop to e2 just
strengthening the f3 pawn rook a to e7
doubling up defending the e7 pawn and
now Russia back to d1 shifting the
bishop over today's diagonal we at night
the Knights to be seven and now Queen
back to h2 and now rook to f7 putting
pressure on the f3 every point here
Bishop the c2 offering you have to
report but again stop Fischer decides
that it's best not to capture it because
after all the trades here you have Queen
to c7 check and you just win the night
here on b7 so stockfish instead goes
Knight to d6
and now Bishop to d3 guarding the the C
4 square in the night C 4 it just the
same and now the bishop characters in c4
will be captures on c4 this will allow
stop wish to use the semi open B file
for attack against the White King we
have Queen - e - now piling up on the e6
pawn here and now look after East 7
defending and we have worked at E 5 we
have a 5 by black and now King to a 1
with a 4 by black and now Quinta a 3 and
now basically we start our what we call
the dance of the engines with King g7
king - a - now King to h7 rock - D - we
have a queen - g7 now just the Rema
nuvaring pieces came to a 1 Queen to f7
and rook back to d4 now Queen g7 we have
Queen e1 and Queen to f7 so it doesn't
seem like either side can make progress
those two rooks are very much needed
here to guard the e6 pawn but both of
them are still very eager to win this
game Queen III we have Queen g7 King b1
and Queen to f8 now we have King back to
a 227 and now King to a 1 we have King
to a trait rook to d2 now and quinta f8
followed by King to eat working to a -
King h7 and rook to G - now I just put
in the work to to a different square not
not to repeat any positions three times
Queen g7 and now rook to f2
we have Queen back to f8 and now rook to
G to Queen to g7 once again rogue back
to f2 once again Queen to f8 and now if
you don't want to repeat the third time
alia pushes f4 so okay we have a pawn
move and something happens in the
position again we continue with our
dance Queen to f7 with rook to G to
marking to g7 and row back to e - we've
worked a b7 now saying are you may be
interested in this pawn here but if if
white were to capture here then after
all the trades on e6 this rook comes to
f6 to f7 and you can either defend the
e4 pawn but we're gonna repeat this
position a few times so we're gonna
we're gonna show it Queen back to d4 now
threatening all sorts of nasty discovery
so King h7 Queen back to e3 came back to
g7 and now like I said if if you capture
and after all of the Capra's Queen
capture screen captures and rook
captures rook to f7 comes with an attack
on the f4 pony and you cannot defend it
you have to start a race but then it's
just basically a draw rook captures here
real captures here captures here and now
after check you're gonna go back and
you're gonna push this pawn d4 captures
captures and you get this position three
against three
where it's a fast a pawn against the
past h-bond both of them fairly
similarly advanced and it should be it
will be a draw so after King g7 we have
ripped d2 by Lila and now rook 87 we
have Queen to b4 again threatening nasty
discoveries King h7 and Queen back to e3
we have Queen to d8 now and Queen e1
we've came to g7 and now Quinta III
Queen to d7 and Queen to b4 now again
threatening nasty discoveries King to g8
oh just getting out of the way and rook
D to e - now again trying to pile up on
the e-file Queen to b5 now threatening
Queen Queen to b3 check and then if the
Queen moves maybe you can have some
Queen to d1 ideas so King a1 not
allowing this check and now Queen back
to D 7 where the Queen is much more
useful guarding at the pawn here so rook
v to III
and now comes Queen back to ei we have
rook to e1 and the King to h7 rook 332
and the Queen to f7
so again their dance continues we have
looked at a five and now rook to e8
Queen back to f2 and now Queen to d7
rook 1 to e 2 in the now Queen back to
f7 rook e1 we have worked the b3 but
Queen back the e3 again putting pressure
on this guy here and repeating rook to
b7 again the same thing if you capture
rook f7 will come with an attack on the
pawn you will not be able to defend it
so rook F 1 and now rook to e7 again
look back the e1 and rook to e8
repeating and now as Leela again does
not want to draw first first Levi said
she doesn't want to draw when g5 was
played an f4 was played and now even f5
is played to avoid the wrong Oliva still
does everything to win of course you
cannot capture with this point since you
lose the rooks og captures on f5 and now
rook to d1 just just nicely repeating
for example if rook captures here and
then pawn captures you will be able to
pick up the rook so look beat East 7
doubling up here and now look back to e
1 again the dance continues we have
worked the b7 and rook to d1 again with
the same threat rugby to e7 stockfish
even though grabbed another pawn is very
happy with the draw here look back to f1
we have King to g8 and now rook to f4
impossible for black to make any
breakthroughs here we have King to g7
Queen to d4 again threatening nasty
discoveries King to h7 and now rook back
to F 1 we have rook to b8 and Quinta III
we have rugby t8 and now Quinta e2 we
have King to g7 and again
rook to f2 now Quinta h7 stop it just
has to repeat moves wait and see what
will happen work the f1 King to g8 and
now comes Queen to III we think the h7
now comes King gay - and King to g7
we've looked f2 now comes King to g8 and
rook the e2 so the dance continues as
the title would suggest we've worked to
be seven and now King to a one King to
g7 and now Queen to d4 again threatening
discoveries and again King to h7 we have
Queen back to f2 and King to g8 we have
Queen to III and now comes Queen to g6
blockading the g5 pawn now again if you
trade here for example rook captures who
will capture screen capture screen
captures and the rook captures now the
problem is f4 and this pawn starts
marching forward and if you blockaded
rook to f7 and once the rooks get traded
off the White King is simply too far
away from the action to to help out with
with the the past F pawn so after Queen
to g6 I just moved back the e1 by Leela
and now came to h7 we have rook to d1
and now rook beat the b8 just shifting
shifting the rooks route back to e one
rook to b7 rook the f1 and now rook eat
rogue back sorry rook 87 we have Queen
to e 1 again we have Quinta I ate and
Quinta e 2 we have King to g8 rook to d1
and now Queen to f7 so still stock is
just repeating moves and Leela is trying
out every possible option on how to win
the game
rook e1 we have rook B to d7 and now
rook to g1 we have Queen to g6 again
blocking the Jeep on so it cannot be
pushed and now rook f1 Queen to f7 and
now comes Queen e3 look back the b7 and
rook to e1 and the Queen to d8 like I
said this this is a gruesome game rook
to d1 and Queen to b5 now again with
ideas of getting the Queen to b3 maybe
putting some pressure here but also just
threatening a Queen captures and B -
checkmate
so Queen e2 defending and now Queen back
to a e8 we have rook the d2 adding
another defender to the second rank and
rook B to d7 now we have
rook to d1 and rook to d6 now we have
Queen III Queen to g6 now again
blockading the pawn here keeping an eye
on the e6 pawn and the Queen to c5 now
Leela successfully infiltrates the Queen
side we rook eat the d7 now the sorry
look II 37 now doubling up on the D file
so the rooks are protected and looked F
1 now we have Queen to f7 and rook back
to d1 now King to h7 and Rho DT 1 again
there there's no way to create any sort
of a breakthrough here we have King g7
and King b1 now rook to b8 and now Queen
back to e3 as there wasn't all that much
to do on the Queen side we have worked
the f8 and now Queen to c5 putting
pressure on the rook here looked a 6 and
now Queen back to e3 we have Queen to g6
and Queen back to c5 with King to g8 and
now King to a-1 Queen to f7 again and
Queen tabby 5 now attacking the rook but
rook after a 8 now just defending the
rook and finally legal a decides to go
for it with g6 so giving up yet another
pawn and now this is very dangerous
territory because stockfish captures and
now stockfish is up 2 points if this is
not winning then it's losing so rook 5
back to e 2 now hopefully you want to
get your roofs over to the G file King -
a trade by stockfish and now Queen to d7
again putting pressure on the pawn here
but here are very successful defends by
stockfish rook 8 to a 7 just getting
getting away the Queen from from the 7th
rank but also from the defense of from
the attack against the pawn queen to be
5 and now Queen to g8 another very
interesting move asking Leela you are
now down to pawn so even ideas like this
will not be possible if rook captures
rook captures rook captures Queen
captures now yes you can deliver check
King goes somewhere g7 Queen captures
with check but then after the Queen
blocks Queen before
check we get this position but it's
again it's it's upon up and even though
in human games upon off pawn up in a
Quincy a queen opponent game can often
result in a draw stockfish is very
confident that he can win this and Lila
decides against it so rook the h2 we
would move to say the least
looked a eight and now comes the Queen
to c5 she trying to shift the Queen over
at this diagonal we have Queen to f7 now
just defending everything and the Queen
to d4 check we have King to h7 and rook
to g2 now preparing to double up rooks
and the G file so rook the g8 of course
not allowing that and here
Lilla trades once if you don't then
black will control the G file so you've
really basically achieved nothing by
giving up all those pawns so real
characters Queen captures and now look
the g1 again grabbing hold of the G file
we have E 5 now trying to trade Queens
as well black is still up to pawns so
Queen c5 and now we have Queen to f7
still just keeping an eye on all the
pawns here and here rook the g5 by Leela
here Leela could go for this bond but
the problem is black can just start
pushing f4 and after we trade
well for example rookie actress and e5
look the e6
and now after rook to b8 going after the
back rank you could play rook to f6 and
just start pushing the pawn Queen
captures sorry Queen captures here and
now you push f3 and the pawn is too too
far advanced for example rook d7 Queen
captures Queen captures and now you're
going to get 21 check King moves and the
Queen to d5 and with the with the F
point so far advanced it will be winning
as white white it does not have a
perpetual here black will be able to
wiggle out since the Queen controls f7
so after this Queen to f7
we have looked to g5 instead of rook to
d1 by Leela
going after well putting pressure on on
the pawns here and
Ruth to g6 now by stockfish incredible
defense as well
if captures captures then it's a queen
opponent in which doctors being up two
points so you cannot trade Queen
captures on h5 instead by Lila and now
look the h6 we have rook to g5 and rook
captures on h4 and now the black rook
infiltrates as well
rook the g1 stopping the rook from
entering the the first rank and now F
force doctor starts pushing the past
pawn or pawns Queen f2 and now rook back
to h6 we have King to be one and now
rook to h5 we have Quinta linking back
to a to end now even if or and now those
two connected past bones are are well
excellent bones we need to just waiting
to see what chakras will do and now f3
and it seems like from that position
where they played over a hundred moves
back and forth where legal I decided to
play g5 then F for then f5 then g6 just
give up all those pawns from a
completely drawn in a drawn game to a
completely lost game now that all these
passports are marching forward it's
really really just incredible stuff
Queen f2 and now Queen to c7 we have
Queen to e3
block block hitting those pawns Queen to
f7 a queen to f2 again not allowing the
pond to be pushed Queen to c7 now we
have Quinta III and our stock which of
course not interested in a draw rook h3
we have rook to d1 attacking the pawn
and Queen b7 just defending it we have
worked to be one getting the rockered
way and also well preparing to defend
against some very nasty threats here and
the Queen back to f7 again ready to push
the f1 Queen f2 blocking and now King to
g6 stock which starts bringing the King
into the game we have root 2 G 1 check
King to f5 and now Queen to c5
just pinning that pawn here nicely but
King f4 that we have Queen to b6 check
King to III and Queen to b6 check now
King te 2 and now comes Queen to d4 and
now that there were no more checks
finally stock forgets f2 in so this was
neither to get DF to move in you had to
bring the King into the game so queen d1
check
luckily for stock fish there is one move
King III queen D fourth check and now
the King goes back King F three Queen D
one check King F for Queen D to check
King now goes back or rather the check
is blocked with III we have Queen to d4
with check and came back to f5 now the
rook nicely guards the e3 pawn queen to
g4 check and now comes King to f6 so if
you capture the rook black just brings
another Queen into the game so Queen
back the d4 with check King e7 and now
comes a queen bee five with check King
d7 and finally rook to g7 saving the
rook and also winning the Queen but
that's of little use since dogfish
brings another Queen into the game and
now we have Queen d5 check the Queen
cannot capture due to the pin
so King e8 and now you don't have a lot
of options you have to continue checking
the King King e7 we have Queen - b7 with
check King - f8 now that the Rope is
under attack you have to trade not much
to do there rook captures Queen captures
and then out comes Queen back to see a
twit check you will win the rook on h3
interestingly but black is left with a
past
III pawns so King g7 Queen captures on
h3 and now comes eetu and luckily you
don't have a check to pick up the pawn
sorry Queen captures on H 3 and E 2 I
don't know I don't know why I repeated
that Queen to h4 with check and now we
have Queen to f6 blocking Queen to g3
keeping an eye on the queening square
but now Queen e6 preparing to push and
now White has to start with all the
checks Queen c7 check King to e8 we have
Queen to b8 with
check King d7 and now the King once
again has to help out with the defense
of the past pawn queen b7 checking these
six with Queen b6 check King to d5 now
comes Queen b7 check out King a 5 and
now
- h1 now guarding the queening square as
the Queen no longer supports it King the
f4 and now Queen h2 check that we have
King III Queen - g1 with checking today
- and now Quinta d4 with check King to
see - and now there are no more checks
so Queen after pinning the pawn but now
Quinta efore giving white a move
centralizing the Queen Queen back to h2
and now King's the d1 preparing to push
the pawn and here Queen to h5 again
pinning it from behind we have King back
to C - and now Queen sorry Queen to c2
not King to c2 Queen to c2 and now
defending the pawn so the king can go to
C 1 but now Queen to G for keeping the
pin but the King to see one Queen to g1
width check and now Queen to d1 and now
after Queen to g5 check we have Queen to
d2 and finally any checks now will be
met with E 1 Queen but as there is
nothing better to do and engines don't
really have a sense of humor Queen the
g1 check was played II won with Queen
and now Queen captures anyone we have
Queen captures anyone and now well
luckily for for stockfish leah has a
move so you know you don't run into any
stalemates king - a one here we have
king the c2 a discovered check where
king - a - and it was in this position
that leave at just 0 resigned the game
before before stockfish managed to
deliver checkmate in one move so a bit
of anticlimactic into the game a hundred
and ninety six games moves without
without allowing the checkmate to be
seen on the board with yeah I already
thought that wow this is definitely the
longest game I've ever shown on the
channel I really wanted to congratulate
everyone for lasting over 200 moves but
India and it's only a hundred and ninety
six you know now all of that dancing and
not even reaching move 200 so yeah
that's a bit of a shame but yeah a
really really incredible stuff first
Lila refuses draw bare repetition before
that decision to push g5 then again
before the decision to push a 4 then
again before a 5 and then again before
g6
so really
reminding me of my own games where you
just you know don't wanna draw and you
over push and then you lose the game
terribly so this is what happened to
leave it here but I'm very happy that
she will still you know try try and win
instead of just just drawing the games
but this is the first victory in the
match with the black pieces and with
this wind stop fish equalizes the match
at eight eight after after sixteen games
but it is a hundred game match so
playing even more games to go we'll see
what happens and who will who will take
the lead yeah now once again that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
congratulations to everyone who stayed
until the end I know it wasn't an easy
thing to do but it is it is quite the
game I would also like to thank any
closure Bartlett's assault systems evv
gmbh Cloud Strife
dr. hall net and the William scholtes
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous video
Sarah thanks all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world and speaking of Cloud
Strife I've actually pre-ordered the
Final Fantasy 7 remake more than a year
ago and it should arrive like today
maybe or maybe tomorrow so hopefully
hopefully it does as soon as possible
but yeah I think you'll I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day